[موسيقى]
مساء الخير بعيدا عن الكاميرات وخلف
الابواب المغلقه تكثف اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن من جهودها لاقناع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بالتطبيع مع
اسرائيل قبل نهايه العام الجاريث 2023
ولتحقيق هذا الهدف بتتواصل الجوالات
المكوكيه بين الرياض وتل ابيب مؤخرا من
جانب مسؤولين امريكان كبار كان اخرهم الذي
ظهر الرياض يوم 8 يونيو الماضي وبعدها
اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا مدته 40 دقيقه اطلع
خلاله رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو على شروط المملكه للتطبيع معها
وفقا
لتسريبات حصلت عليها صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
المفاوضات سريه برمتها ولكن كما قال وزير
الدفاع الامريكي والسياسي الامريكي
الراحل المعروف دونالدراميسفيلد ذات مره
الحكومه الامريكيه لا تستطيع ان تكتم سرا
طبعا على سبيل المبالغه يعني
على العموم عدد من المسؤولين الامريكان
والاسرائيليين اكدوا لصحف كبيره ومراكز
ابحاث معتبره في واشنطن ان بيضن
والاسرائيليين ياملون في اتمام هذا
الاتفاق قبل نهايه هذا العام لعده اسباب
اولها قبل ان ينشغل الرئيس الامريكي
بالانتخابات التي سوف تعقد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التي سوف تعقد في نوفمبر 202
انه يامول اذا نجحت جهوده وتحققت التطبيع
ان يكون ذلك انجاز خارجي يدعم فرص بايدن
في الانتخابات لانه هيتباهى بهذا الانجاز
كما تباها ترامب
بنجاحه في اتمام الاتفاقات الابراهيميه
بين اسرائيل واربعه الدول العربيه في
الفين وعشرين
نتنياهو اكثر حماسا من بيض لانه ايضا
يتمنى اذا تم هذا الاتفاق ان يتمكن من
انقاذ الماذومه والتي قد تنهار مع استمرار
الاحتجاجات ضده منذ 23 اسبوعا لكن بخلاف
الاعتبارات الانتخابيه اتفاق مع السعوديه
من شانه ان يحقق ثلاث نتائج بتامل فيها
واشنطن تل ابيب واحد انقاذ التحالف
المعادي لايران والذي ضعف وتراجع كثيرا
بعد اتفاقات المصالحه الاخيره بين ايران
وبعض جيرانها وعلى راسهم طبعا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والان المفاوضات تجري
بين
الطهران والقاهره
وايران والمملكه الاردنيه ومملكه البحرين
الى اخره هذا امر يقلق جدا الاسرائيليين
ولا يسعد الامريكان
ان هذا الاتفاق او التقارب او التطبيع بين
السعوديه واسرائيل من شانه ابطاء تقارب
السعوديه مع الصين وربما روسيا وهو تقارب
يقلق الامريكان
ثلاثه وهو الاهم للاسرائيليين على وجه
التحديد انه هذا التطبيع من شانه تهميش
القضيه الفلسطينيه اكثر واكثر هذا بديهي
مع كل دوله تطبع مع اسرائيل دون حل للقضيه
الفلسطينيه تقل حاجه اسرائيل للدخول في
مفاوضات مع الفلسطينيين لكن الرغبه
الامريكيه والاسرائيليه بتصطدم بالشروط
السعوديه والتي يراها الجانبان صعبه جدا
لكن قبل الحديث عن شروط السعوديين من
المهم ان نفهم كيف يفكر السعوديون
السعوديه بتدرك مدى حاجه وحماس امريكا
واسرائيل لهذا التطبيق مفهوم طبعا تطبيعي
اسرائيل مع ارض الحرمين الشريفين والدوله
صاحبه اكبر اقتصاد في المنطقه نقطه تحول
مهمه لوضع اسرائيل في المنطقه
لكن في المقابل السعوديه ليس لديها حوافز
حقيقيه للاقبال على هذه الخطوه ما الذي
يمكن ان تحصل عليه من هذا التطبيع
اذا قسمنا الدول
وقعت اتفاقات سلام وتطبيع مع اسرائيل
هنلاقيهم ان هو يعني مجموعه من الدول تمت
على مرحلتين ست دول
بالنسبه لمصر والاردن مصر في اواخر
السبعينات
والاردن في سنه 94 دي الدول مواجهه وقعت
اتفاقات سلام مع اسرائيل لانهاء حاله حرب
لم يعد من الممكن بالنسبه لهم استمرارها
وبالتالي وقعوا اتفاقيه اتفاقات سلام مع
اسرائيل لانهاء حاله الحرب والسعوديه ليست
في حاله حرب مع اسرائيل وليست مهدده بشكل
مباشر من جانب اسرائيل
اما الدول الاربعه اللي وقعوا لاحقا مع
اسرائيل اتفاقات تطبيع في 2020 السودان
المغرب البحرين الامارات فقط فعلوا ذلك
تحت ضغوط واغراء من الولايات المتحده وكل
دوله طلبت مقابله لاتمام هذا التطبيع على
سبيل المثال المغرب وقعت اتفاق سلام
للحصول على اعتراف امريكا بسيادته علاء
الصحراء السودان طلب رفع اسمه من قائمه
الدول الراعيه للارهاب وهكذا السعوديه
ليست في حاجه لكل ذلك
ما ترغب فيه ويمكن الحصول عليه وضع تحت
كلمه يمكن الحصول عليه متاح بلا تطبيع
اضف الى ذلك ان التطبيع مخاطره بالنظر الى
رفض الغالبيه من السعوديين حتى الان
التطبيع مع الكيان الصهيوني وما ثم ان
التطبيع قد يضر بمكانتها او سوف يضر
بمكانتها في العالم الاسلامي وعليه قررت
السعوديه الغير متلهفه ان تطرح شروطا
للتطبيع شروطا
طموحه جدا للتطبيع فاذا لم تتحقق لم نخسر
شيئا انا لا اريد التطبيع يعني من الاساس
وان تحققت تكون مغامره السعوديه او تكون
السعوديه قد حصلت على ثمن ما كان لها ابدا
ان تحصل عليه دون ان تقبل على هذا التطبيع
مع اسرائيل يعني باختصار تريده مقابلا
عاليا جدا ثمنا كبيرا جدا لاتمام هذه
الخطوه
ما هي الشروط السعوديه وفقا للتسريبات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه وضعت تحت كلمه
التسريبات الامريكيه خطا لان السعوديين لا
يتحدثون
لا يتحدثون علنا عن هذه المفاوضات واحد
الشرط الاول التزام امريكي رسمي بالدفاع
عن المملكه العربيه السعوديه اي اتفاق
دفاع مشترك على غرار التزام الولايات
المتحده تجاه دول الناتو اللي هي دول حلف
شمال الاطلسي
بالاضافه الى صفقات سلاح نوعيه متطوره على
غرار الاسلحه التي تحصل عليها اسرائيل
وتحرم منها باقي دول المنطقه
اثنين دعم امريكي لبرنامج نووي سعودي سلمي
كبير وطموح ملاحظه مصدر هذه التسريبات او
هذه الشروط هو تسريبات من المسؤولين
الامريكان الذين تحدثوا تكرارا ومرارا الى
عدد من اكبر وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
ومراكز الابحاث المهمه هناك ومنها على
سبيل المثال وليس الحصر معهد واشنطن
لسياسات الشرق الادنى وهو مركز ابحاث مؤيد
لاسرائيل ومعني جدا بمتابعه يعني مسار
التطبيع بين اسرائيل وكل الدول المقاطعه
لها وخصوصا الدول الاسلاميه والعربيه وهذا
المعهد يزور اعطائه الرياض بانتظام واخر
زياره
[موسيقى]
هو انه لا تضيع مع اسرائيل الا بعد قيام
دوله فلسطينيه ولا يتحدثون ابدا علنا على
المفاوضات الجاريه مع الامريكان
ولكن هذا الشرط وهذا امر ملفت للنظر اللي
هو شرط قيام دوله فلسطينيه لا يشير اليه
الامريكان ولا الاسرائيليون في تسريباتهم
لهذه الصحف وكانهم يعتبرونه انه ليس عقبه
ما يعني قناعتهم انه يمكن اقناع السعوديين
بتجاوز هذا الشرط دي قناعتهم ينجحوا فيها
او لا ينجحوا هذه قصه اخرى هذه مجرد
ملحوصه
ما مشكله هذه الشروط بالنسبه للامريكان
والاسرائيليين ولماذا يعتبرونها شروطا شبه
مستحيله الشرط الاول اللي هو اتفاق ملزم
للدفاع عن المملكه العربيه السعوديه كان
وما زال مرفوودا لاسباب كثيره لانه ببساطه
الامريكان في مشاكل المنطقه العقود وهي
المشاكل اللي اراد الامريكان تجاوزها
وقلنا كتير قوي في حلقات سابقه انه تصور
الامريكان انهم عاوزين يتخففوا من
التزماتهم في المنطقه ولكن يظلوا يستفيدوا
منها
ثم ان رغبه الرياض في الحصول على اسلحه
متطوره
يخل بمبدا التفوق الاسرائيلي الكاس على كل
دول الجوار الذي يعني تعهدت به امريكا
واصبح قانونا ملزما منذ يعني السبعينات
بعد حرب 73
ما يعني ان الكونجرس لن يمرر بسهوله مثل
هذا الاتفاق ولن يسمح ايضا به بسهوله
بحصول السعوديه على صفقات السلاح المتطور
الذي تطالب به الاداره الامريكيه السعوديه
مش بتطالب به الاداره دي بتطالب به
الاداره واي اداره تاتي لان هذا الاتفاق
لن يكون اتفاقا سياسيا مثل الاتفاق
النووي بين اداره اوباما والايرانيين هي
عاوزه اتفاق ملزم يقره الكونجرس ولا
يستطيع اي رئيس امريكا ان يتنصل منه
الشرط الثاني والذي يتفاوض الامريكان مع
السعوديين بخصوصهم منذ 2012 ايضا ما زال
مرفوضا يتعلق برغبه السعوديه الطموحه
لبناء برنامج نووي كبير
بتكنولوجيا امريكيه في المقام الاول ما
مشكله ان يحصل السعوديون على برنامج
النووي سلمي والسعوديين بيقولوا عاوزينه
برنامج سلمى وخاضع لكل اشتراطات المجتمع
الدولي وتحت رقابه الوكاله الطاقه الذريه
وكل شيء ما المشكله ما كثير من دول العالم
لديها برنامج نووي سلمى المشكله باختصار
كما فهمته يعني من مسؤولين متعددين ومما
نشر انه السعوديين لا يريدون
ببساطه مفاعل او مجموعه مفاعلات نوويه على
المفتاح
يقوم الاجانب بتشغيله لا ده هم عاوزين
حاجه تانيه خالص هم يريدون توطينا
لتكنولوجيا تخصيب اليورانيوم بحيث تكون
السعوديه التي يعتقد ان لديها مخزون كبير
جدا من اليورانيوم جاري التنقيب عنه ان
تكون مركزا لصناعه تخصيب اليورانيوم في
العالم بحيث تستخدمه محليا لتوليد الطاقه
وكل الاستخدامات السلميه الاخرى
وتصدره لمن يحتاج اليه مخصبا ما يعزز من
موارد المملكه الاقتصاديه هي تريد من
امريكا ان تساعدها في الحصول على هذه
التكنولوجيا النموذج اللي بيفكر فيه
السعوديون هو نموذج او هو تكراره لتجربه
ارامكو مع الامريكان ارامكو عملاق النفط
في العالم
بدا كمشروع مشترك سعودي امريكي ثم بعد ان
تعلم السعوديون الصناعه خرج الامريكان او
اخرج الامريكان واصبحت السعوديه هي من
تديره من الالف للياء الامريكان من جانبهم
لا يثقون في نوايا السعوديه التي سبق
وسرحت بانها ستطور سلاحا نوويا ان امتلك
ان امتلك ايران القنبله
ويريدون ان يطبقوا على السعوديه نفس
الشروط نفس شروط تعاونهم مع دول اخرى وفقا
لما يعرف باتفاق الضمانات الامريكا او
اتفاق 123 للتعاون السلمي وما هو اتفاق
123 وببساطه اتفاق ضمانات
بتتاكد امريكا
بموجبه ان الدوله لامريكا سوف تساعدها
تكنولوجيا لن تتمكن ابدا من تطوير قدراتها
النوويه لتصبح دوله نوويه عسكريه قبل
مساعده اي دوله نوويا بتفرض الولايات
المتحده شروطا قاسيه هدفها التاكد تماما
من ان هذه الدول لن تتمكن من امتلاك قدرات
النوويه عسكريه وبتشمل هذه الشروط احيانا
حظر تخصيب اليورانيوم او اعاده معالجه
الوقود على اراضي هذه الدوله الدوله او
هذه الدول يعني وفقت بالمناسبه الامارات
وتايوان على سبيل المثال على اتفاقات
مماثله ووقعوا على اتفاق 123 اللي هو
عباره عن بند في
قانون قانون وكاله الطاقه الذريه
الامريكيه باسم اتفاقات 123 وبالتالي
باختصار يرفض المسؤولون السعوديون حتى
الان الالتزام بالقيود التي من شانها ان
تقوي الطموحاتهم او قدرتهم على تخصيب
اليورانيوم وبيعه وهم يتفاوضون
نوويا يعني بشكل معلن ما عدد من الدول
الاخرى التي يمكن ان تساعدهم في حاله رفض
الامريكان المساعده بعد هذه الدول هم اربع
دول تحديدا احنا بنتكلم على فرنسا وبنتكلم
على كوريا الجنوبيه وبنتكلم على
الصين وبنتكلم على روسيا طبعا بالنسبه
لكوريا الجنوبيه وفرنسا ربما يوافقون على
الشروط السعوديه وان كان هذا امرا قد
يكونوا صعبا قليلا ان هذه الشركات ان فعلت
ذلك هي دول حليفه للولايات المتحده ربما
تغامر يعني بالدخول في مواجهه مع الولايات
المتحده وتخضع ايضا لضغوط الاسرائيليه
يمكن ان تكون روسيا والصين اختيار افضل
خصوصا ان هم قطعوا بالفعل شوطا فيما يتعلق
بالاتفاق مع الصينيين اللي وقعوا معهم
مذكره تفاهم مبدئيا لبناء مفاعل نووي في
2016 ثم عقدا اخر للتنقيب عن اليورانيوم
في الاراضي السعوديه في 2017
بالاضافه الى صعوبه الشرطين اللي انا اشرت
اليهم اللي هو اتفاق اتفاق دفاع مشترك
ملزم وعقود سلاح متقدمه ثم بناء برنامج
نووي سلبي متطور يستطيع السعوديون فيه ان
يخصبوا اليورانيوم على اراضيهم وان يبيعوه
الى من يحتاج بالاضافه لصعوبه هذين
الشرطين هناك مجموعه اخرى من التعقيدات من
التعقيدات اللي
بتجعل من تنفيذ
الشروط السعوديه امرا بالغ الصعوبه على
الاداره الامريكيه وعلى الاسرائيلي هنا
ايضا اول هذه التعقيدات هناك جناح في
الحزب الديمقراطي يشار اليه عاده باسم
التقدميين او اليسار التقدمي هم مش يسار
بالمعنى
القديم يعني ولكن هذا التيار الذي تحدثنا
عنه قديمه تحدثنا عنه سابقا يجعل من القيم
الليبراليه اللي هي الحريات الديمقراط
حقوق الانسان اهم محور للسياسه الخارجيه
لامريكا وهم من كانوا السبب الرئيسي في
التصريحات العنيفه لبيض اثناء حملته
الانتخابيه ضد محمد بن سلمان وعدد من قاده
العالم من بينهم الرئيس التركي اردوغان
والرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي هذا
التيار متعاطف مع الفلسطينيين
باعتبارهم شعب مقهور
ووفقا لاستطلاع اجرتهم مؤسسه قلب مثلا في
مارس 2023
49% من الديمقراطيين قالوا انهم يتعاطفون
اكثر مع الفلسطينيين وهو تحول تاريخي في
توجهات انصار هذا الحزب
ونفس هذا الجناح يخجل من دعم حكومه
نتنياهو الحاليه باعتبارها حكومه متطرفين
هذا الجناح يرفض محاولات بيض للتطبيع بين
السعوديه والاسرائيليين لانها دعم لحكومه
نتنياهو المتطرفه
ولاداره السعوديه الحاليه او اي حكومه
سعوديه في الحقيقه لانهم يرونها حكومه
الدوله مستبده معاديه لحقوق الانسان في
يوليو 2022
مجموعه من الديمقراطيين اللي بيمثلوا هذا
التيار اللي هم البروجراسيف او التقدميين
دعوا عدد من كتبوا خطابا وجهوه الى الرئيس
الامريكي قبل توجهه الى زياره الرياض في
يوليو من العام الماضي
وطالبوه في هذا الخطاب بضروره خفض
العلاقات مع السعوديه وذلك عقابا لها على
خمسه مشكلات واحد سياسه السعوديه الضاره
بامريكا فيما يتعلق بالنفط هم بيشتغلوا
لمصالحهم وليس لمصالح امريكا وده عيب
المفروض السعوديه تشتغل لمصالح امريكا
اثنين الحرب في اليمن ثلاثه اعتقال نشطاء
حقوق الانسان ومسار التحقيقات في مقتل
جمال خاشقجي الذي ما زال يمثل
مطلبا من جانب هؤلاء ويصرون على ضروره
التدقيق فيه اربعه جهود حيازه التكنولوجيا
النوويه
المتطوره من جانب المملكه
خمسه التعاون العسكري مع الصين
ده اول تعقيد لاتمام عمليه التطبيع وجود
هذا التيار بيخلي الرئيس الامريكي وفكر
مرتين لانه ان اقبل على هذا التطبيع ربما
يخاطر بخساره اصواتهم اثنين مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الامريكيه يرغب الجمهوريون
المتحمسون ليه طبعا تطبيقا وتطبيعا سعوديا
اسرائيليا من حرمان بيض من تحقيق هذا
الانجاز الدبلوماسي قبل الانتخابات يريدون
ان يحتفظوا بهذا الانجاز لانفسهم لانفسهم
ان جاؤوا الى البيت الابيض في نهايه 2024
واول 2025
وجود حكومه اسرائيليه متطرفه بقياده
نتنياهو ومجموعه من اكثر
المستوطنين
والجماعات المهوسه يعني دينيا في تل ابيب
على قمه السلطه هناك والمصره على قمع
الفلسطينيين وترفض اي تعهد ولو انشائي
بالتسويه مع الفلسطينيين بيحرج السعوديين
الذين يصرون علنا على ان قيام دوله
فلسطينيه شرط اساسي للتطبيع لا تنسوا ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه قطعت الطريق على
نفسها باعلانها المتكرر انه لا تضيع مع
اسرائيل الا بعد قيام دوله فلسطينيه يبدو
ان السعوديين يفضلون اتمام هذا التطبيع ان
تم مع الاداره المقبله التي يفضلونها
جمهوريه على الاقل حتى لا يكافئوا بايدن
الديمقراطي الذي اساء الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كثيرا منذ ان جاء الى البيت
الابيض في نهايه وعشرين اذا كل هذه
اعتبارات بتجعل من اتمام التطبيع السعودي
الاسرائيلي قبل نهايه فتره بايدن شبه
مستحيله اذا على ماذا يراهن الرئيس
الامريكي اذا كان الرئيس الامريكي لا يرى
بصيص امل لاتمام هذا التطبيع ما كان له ان
يستثمر الكثير من الجهد والوقت على مدار
شهور في مفاوضات مضنيه مع السعوديين
والاسرائيليين انا قلت لحضراتكم ان الرئيس
الامريكي بيرسل وفدا بعد وفدا بعد وفد الى
الاسر والى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وكلها وفود عاليه المستوى حدثتكم عن
بلينكن الذي جاء الى الرياض يوم 8 يونيو
الماضي ثم تحدث الى بنيامين نتنياهو
اربعين دقيقه ليخبره بشروط السعوديين
للتطبيع معهم وبعده جاء وفد من كبار
المسؤولين في الاداره الامريكيه ليتحدث مع
السعوديين والاسرائيليين وقبلهما جيك
سالبن مستشار الامن القومي الذي حضر الى
المملكه وايضا تحدث الى الاسرائيليين
اسرائيليين في مايو الماضي لو كل هؤلاء
المسؤولين راوا انه لا امله ونقلوا ذلك
للرئيس الامريكي لاغلق الملف برمته اذا
على ماذا يراهن الرئيس الامريكي يبدو ان
الرئيس الامريكي بيراهن على مجموعه من
الامور واحد انه قادر على تمرير اتفاق
التطبيع السعودي الاسرائيلي
والوفاء باكبر قدر ممكن من الشروط
السعوديه داخل الكونجرس لان هذا الاتفاق
سوف يتم تسويقه على انه اولا يحمل مصلحه
لاسرائيل وعندما يتعلق الامر باسرائيل فان
كثيرا من اعضاء الكونجرس مستعدين ان
يتجاوزوا الكثير من العقوبات من اجل عيون
اسرائيل
وتسويق الاتفاق ايضا على انه لا يتعلق فقط
باسرائيل وانه مهم جدا للمصالح الامريكيه
ومهم جدا ايضا للفلسطينيين ما يرضي عدد من
اعضاء الكونجرس الذين يتعاطفون مع
الفلسطينيين من ناحيه
وياخذون موقفا عدائيا مع السعوديه
باعتبارها حكومه مستبده ومع نتنياهو
باعتباره ايضا حكومه مستبده ومتطرفه ولا
يريدون ان يكافؤوهم باي وساطه تجمعهما
لهؤلاء بيض واقطاب ادارته يقولون لهم ان
هذا الاتفاق له فوائد اخرى تتجاوز
السعوديين وتتجاوز الاسرائيليين من شان
هذا الاتفاق ان يحشر ايران في الزاويه
لانه سوف يجعل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في المعسكر الغربي الاسرائيلي تماما
اثنين انه سوف يقلص من نفوس الصين في
المنطقه هذا ايضا يسعد الديمقراطيين
والكمكوريين ثم انه نتنياهو واقداب حكومته
المتطرفه التي لم تبقى الى الابد في
السلطه في اسرائيل في امس الحاجه لاتمام
هذا الاتفاق لاسباب انتخابيه كما اوضحت
لحضراتكم هؤلاء نتنياهو وقتاب حكومته سوف
يكونون حريصين جدا على القبول بالشروط
والضغوط الامريكيه لانهم يدركون انه لا
اتفاق بدون وساطه الولايات المتحده وعليه
فان الولايات المتحده سوف تكون قادره على
الضغط على نتنياهو وحكومته لتحسين احوال
الفلسطينيين وربما البدء في مفاوضات جاده
معهم وتحسين شروط حياتهم
يبدو ايضا انه بيض براهن على قدرته على
اقناع السعوديين بالقبول بشروط
اقل مما يطالبون بها ويبدو انه استانس ذلك
من خلال المفوضين الذين ارسلهم هذا امر
مالوف انه كل طرف بيبدا بشروط عاليه جدا
ثم يبدا في الهبوط بسقف توقعاته وكمان
الطرف المقابل سوف يهبط بسقف توقعاته هذا
ما يقابله بيض ان يهبط بسقف توقعات
السعوديين لتمرير الاتفاق هل ينجح في ذلك
ام يتصلى بالسعوديون هذا امر يجب ان ننتظر
ونراقبه بدقه ويكون لنا معه ان شاء الله
حلقات اخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى لقاء